that's gonna breasts money welcome back
to layers of fear okay so by not
cheating whatsoever apparently one the
paintings
tell there it is it's gonna show me now
okay maybe not now anyway it's three
five no no five four you [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] phone switch back to iPhone you
piece of [ __ ] I trusted you Steve Jobs
oh my god look it's down there
it's eight five three [ __ ] eight
five three oh my god I'm so smart I'll
[ __ ] more phones ah what that again okay
that's kind of cool now it's it's kind
of like we did that
that one disappeared my favorite kind of
doors
awesome thinking you mean breaking a
phone yeah I know I agree can you
believe something all right you're
breaking everything all right where's
the next one come on everything that's
just dropping oh ha ha
loser what a [ __ ]
there's the 3 541 what what a loser
all right they're so satisfying you
should bring back these phones even
though they're very inefficient hey this
game became your blood I just broke all
my legs all three of them Oh for [ __ ]
sake I hate when that happens
all right back aah guys can we chill
chill oh boy I am mm in the pickle right
now oh [ __ ]
well that was fun I really I really
enjoyed that I swear to God if the baby
beard is there I'm gonna be super duper
pissed
are you [ __ ]
what do you do with the document baby
beard the actual phone is ringing now
you deserve this all of it is she
telling me to all live all of it
oh she became olive oil got it hate when
that happens
Oh baby face I thought we were cool god
damn it I'm gonna go ahh you baby-faced
[ __ ] what was I doing in here I had
like a weird trip or some [ __ ] I needed
something to add thee how should I put
it
final touches well that's weird finger I
needed a finger chopped it off easier
than sawing a leg washed it dried it in
an oven fell asleep almost burned it
will I managed to pull this off
it reminds me a little bit about so you
know the story psycho right that is
inspired by an actual person I don't
remember his name but basically he was a
taxidermist so he's very skilled at at
using skin as a fat fabric at like a
leather but he used human skin so he
would make furniture out of human skin
and so once they found him and all his
stuff there was like a chair made us
human skin and all that stuff but it's
just [ __ ] so disgusting and so creepy
oh it's big it's starting to become a
person is that our wife perhaps all
right we have one more secret to uncover
so the way this guy is obsessed with
painting kinda reminds me of the same
thing how about them apples am i right
ladies up top
thank you thank you very much all right
let's keep going
one more secret where are you where are
you little secret come here well aren't
you adorable someone needs to come cut
your [ __ ] toenails
hey no shame on you
Thanks that doesn't hurt my ears at all
thank you very much
I am he's gonna go to the zoo brokkr
like what you've done with the place
wonderful
Oh wrong door sorry this is it that that
this is where I wanted to go this is my
planner long nail that shouldn't I'm oh
boy ah-ha
why don't have to marry such a [ __ ] all
right here we go there you are
Oh what the [ __ ]
hey there's a light here oh that's
that's very creepy I'm just gonna
[ __ ] go [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I'm out
god [ __ ] damn it that's creepy
okay here we are this is great I love
this place now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna yeah yeah don't worry about
it don't worry about it Lisa
did I do it right
it's a pink cool
[ __ ] out
holy [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] creepy
a Ouija board yes No
hope
what do I do it's lit up
okay so once I find a ladder it's gonna
it's kind of like yeah hangman maybe
okay all right what are we going to
spell out though this needs a lot of
better thinking
goddamnit this is so confusing and weird
oh my oh boy oh boy that's a good one
it says nice and clean now at least well
house I run two knives plays look what
is taking so long
open this [ __ ] door need to go open
up hell is Oh God
no no no no no no no no what have you
done
no oh we're gonna take a bath I love
taking a bath hello there Oh I have to
hold down that's kind of Awesome let's
do that again
are you [ __ ] yeah again another one
this is so cool
side mister yeah what are we doing
someone walks in on us in like what are
they doing
you
finally someone had to bear witness
I couldn't just look at my own work art
and the artist needed an audience a
critical eye on things I knew what I had
to do i gauze dit scooped it up like ice
cream felt like a butcher a monster yeah
there was to come something beautiful
from all this filth and washed my hands
after that one
ah here we go what I guess not
guys I don't know what the right answer
is I don't like playing Chinese checkers
this doesn't feel right hey it's the
dolphin man what are you doing me okay
well I guess we'll just fumble around in
the darkness again until we find
somebody click on
No okay well I'm Chinese checkers it is
you win game oh this is it no no I don't
well [ __ ] me I am I'm lost big surprise
are we seriously collecting Chinese
checkers in the darkness best game
nail that
what an epic table flip look at that
[ __ ] ha loser I tried to tell me
something mate well that was fun
let's do that again yeah no I don't
think I got it game I don't think I
quite got it oh oh of course that's the
rat
thank you
this is quality entertainment for you
I'm glad we agree on things now honestly
like I don't [ __ ] get it like I don't
know what triggers things in the [ __ ]
game
so frustrating
oh look there I was supposed to click
there like get out of here you're
getting ridiculous
what's that Nazi babies okay well I
guess we keep fumbling around in the
darkness looking for something to click
on oh now it's this turn what are those
whoa
huh my favorite song music was so much
better back in the day
i am i ah this is just annoying
no is it I can't be the only one like
what what is the point
surely the understand that this is not
entertaining maybe I'm just being an
idiot I don't know
oh my god I don't know what to do you I
guess you can jump forward if you want
to skip this but I don't want to cut too
much in my gameplay I want you guys to
see this just good in the bad and the
ugly
jumping all around so I had to look at
the ceiling and that triggered a Chinese
checker Bravo
that was a fun puzzle I really enjoyed
that
more sure in another room open this
looks nice I like what you've done with
the place
ah now the room open okay hopefully this
one won't be as a ridiculous hey ball
hidin I can't go up other this thank you
thank [ __ ] god um amen
I'm very torn right now cuz it was
really good up to this point and I feel
like it needs more play on uh interact
non-scripted horror i guess if that
makes sense
like in amnesia a lot of the scares are
random because you're you're being
changed or you're being haunted by
someone I'm so I don't mean to like
compare everything to amnesia just
because it's a horror but that sense
it's really terrifying and they have the
right atmosphere for it it just feels
like a missed opportunity um that there
was a lot of times I thought someone was
gonna chase me and it was really scary
but it never happened um there's no real
sense of danger when all there is is
jump scares oh there you are
and I mean essentially this is a key
searching puzzle like we're looking for
keys except they're Chinese checkers and
that's like the lamest form of puzzle if
you ask me
but everything else is so high polish
and the stories are interesting and the
theme and they are design and everything
it's so good but I'm totally I lost the
immersion you know because of all this
[ __ ] part I'm sorry if I seem
negative I'm just being honest
and a lot of times where I'm more
critical it's because the game is
actually good and I think it can do
better but we haven't finished it yet so
maybe it will change but I think we
discovered all the corners oh there's a
kitchen too
come on was easy to find maybe there's
something in here just paintings just
great hey what are we cooking here a
house another Haida
that's strange 2 1 9 o 21 grams that's
correct
oh look who it is
you were my enemy all along weren't you
ah you [ __ ] baby bait face [ __ ]
hey it's rolling teddy he rolls forever
keep on rolling teddy hear a piano where
is come from
that's cool
that's really [ __ ] though
finally we can put the last piece are
you bros ready let's do this
oh we become the painting no we're just
we just got close to it so it was a
portrait all online of our wife
yes that's it oh it's beautiful perfect
just like I always oh whoa whoa what is
this
I don't understand no stop it please
Heath right so close this time
I almost had it
Oh for a guy
where are we going
they're everywhere
huh another one and another one
okay here we go
still got more gameplay but they were
actually all perfect but they are
different no maybe not
that's really interesting this is our
house for the first time it makes sense
executive producer that's an interesting
way to
that's for the corn
nice glasses
it's interesting you appreciate more of
the people that work on the game when
you actually see their faces usually
it's just a [ __ ] text you know except
I'm Sergeant breathing through it so I
shouldn't be talking but it's cool
okay so that was layers of fear um how
do I get out of here there we go we
can't get out of the house I assume
let's try look at our [ __ ] house it's
so wrecked I feel like we see it as it
truly is right now but can we leave it
started off with like this time it's
going to be correct dear sir I didn't
read the note I wanted to read the note
next to the painting dear sir there's a
reminder that your payment was ever do
it closes statement my friends there
must be inform you there were suspended
wait arrange pain for your next 10 days
or okay so we're not paying for our
house anymore I guess or our bills and
they slid that note but we barricaded
ourself in here I hear a crying girl but
where it's coming from here no where is
it coming from No
what about our room really Oh creepy I
keep hearing the girl cream creaming
that's not the right word I don't want
to go to a gig she [ __ ] creepiest [ __ ]
okay well I stand by what I said before
obviously it was a very good game and I
don't mean to be too critical this is
when I really think it could have been
more it's just kind of frustrating in my
opinion I mean we check this out
I don't see what else there is it's the
baby room it's a beautiful house
what about our office there's the
babyface again we really [ __ ] up our
office there's the keys let's get in and
start over there wait how do you walk
down such a weird staircase no more
painting
I hope the note is still there there we
go oh I didn't find all the things
oh there it is again
finishing touch that was layers care
okay yeah um I'm glad I finished it uh
and it was really good but like I I felt
like it they had more to give so I
really hope they make another one and I
would love to play it and I don't think
I have much else to say I just want to
say thank you guys for watching this
playthrough with me I really hope you
enjoyed it and if you did leave a like
and I'll see you bros in whatever next
we're gonna play I really enjoy doing
these and I really enjoyed doing them
with you I like he said the artist
wouldn't be anything without an audience
I'm not an artist but I appreciate it so
thank you and as always stay awesome